a valley woman going to extremes to
protect her home it's been struck by
Vehicles seven times the latest incident
happening about three weeks ago nearly
killing her the homeowner also says
water appearing to come from a nearby RV
park and casino could be partly to blame
now the home is located off Boulder
Highway in India's a news now reporter
Ryan Matthey gets to the source
so this is where a wall yes yes
Monique Brewster bought a home with a
view nearly four years ago it was like
paradise you know now she's picking up
the pieces from when this car slammed
into her home on April 27th this is what
came down on me this my this right here
used to be up against here but she says
this time marks the seventh Collision
onto her property since she's moved in
automatic Gates now sit immobile a
makeshift garage now houses her cars and
even with giant Boulders added to the
property the collisions keep happening
the most recent time she was just feet
away but I'm traumatized I live the
dream of the
it was Beauty and then now it's not to
me
she calls it a recipe for disaster
located at the end of a long stretches
street with no speed bumps but she also
points to this water and when we follow
it Upstream
we find its Origins right here just a
wall away from Arizona Charlie's
from the street it's seemingly from the
casino's RV park but when I asked an
Arizona Charlie's representative says
it's from a county storm drain then a
Clark County representative telling me
in a statement that they've received no
complaints of Still Water there that
turned slimy but after checking because
of this story they're unclear where the
water's from as you can see these are
two different sets of skin marks until a
source is found Brewster says it's not
if there's a next time but when when do
you think you'll be able to leave I
don't know I don't have the money just
to go